ANTHONY BUSHONG: When
getting started with GKE,
it's essential to think about
how you can design for security
across multiple dimensions.
Today, let's review
the first areas
you'll need to consider
when securing access
to your GKE cluster.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
It's important to
start with defining
what cluster access means.
With GKE, there
are two dimensions
in which we access our cluster.
The first dimension
is the GKE API.
This is where users can
perform cluster operations.
Rather than creating
Kubernetes resources,
we use the GKE API to create,
read, update, and delete
GKE clusters.
The second dimension is the
Kubernetes control plane.
This is how we
create, read, update,
and delete Kubernetes
resources in a GKE cluster.
Across both the GKE API and
the Kubernetes control plane,
we want to ensure that users
only have the access they need
and nothing more.
This is called the principle
of least privilege.
Let's review the various
knobs we have available in GKE
to develop a strategy
to achieve this.
Accessing a GKE cluster
starts with GCP Identity
and Access Management, or IAM.
Like most GCP services,
GKE is tightly integrated
with GCP IAM.
In GKE, roles and
permissions can
be assigned to individual users
or an entire Google Group.
This can help greatly as the
surface of your team changes
over time.
One of the quickest
ways to get started
with accessing GKE is using
GCP IAM's predefined roles.
In GKE, there are
predefined roles,
such as admin, developer,
viewer, all of which
can be assigned to user
accounts or a Google Group
using GCP IAM.
It is important to note that
the role will apply to all GKE
clusters in a GCP project.
Once assigned a
predefined role, users
will have a set of permissions
that authorize them
to interact with the GKE API.
This means that they
can perform operations
that align with their
role, whether it's
creating a cluster,
adding a node pool,
or manually triggering
a cluster upgrade.
These predefined
roles also give users
authorization to perform
various actions when interacting
with the Kubernetes API.
Again, it is important to
note that not only does this
apply to all clusters
in a project,
but all namespaces
within a GKE cluster.
Now this can be
really convenient,
especially if you're a team
doing your own development
and your own operations.
GKE's integration
with GCP IAM can
be a single method
for configuring access
to both the GKE API and
Kubernetes resources
within your GKE clusters.
However, if we need
more granular control
to achieve the principle
of least privilege,
we'll have to be a bit more
intentional, configuring
GCP IAM and Kubernetes
Role-Based Access
Control, or RBAC, in
concert with one another.
We can start by looking at
creating a custom GCP IAM role.
Rather than utilizing
the predefined roles
that GKE provides,
we can consider
creating a custom GCP IAM
role with lesser permission.
We can then use Kubernetes
RBAC to define user access when
interacting with the Kubernetes
control plane in a GKE cluster.
Kubernetes RBAC allows us
to enable granular control
over what namespaces and
what Kubernetes resources
that users can interact
with on a per-cluster basis.
An example of this
in action would
be to define a GCP IAM
custom role for users
that don't need to manage
the GKE cluster lifecycle,
but do need to interact
with the Kubernetes control
plane for various
clusters in their project.
In this scenario,
the custom role
would be minimal,
only allowing the user
get permissions with
the GKE API, which
enables them to get their
credentials to access
the Kubernetes control plane.
But by default, this
would not give them
permissions to actually
perform any actions
against the Kubernetes
control plane.
Instead any permissions when
interacting with the Kubernetes
control plane would be defined
in Kubernetes RBAC, which
can give us the
granularity we need
to achieve the principle
of least privilege.
Now once we have found the right
balance of our GCP IAM roles
and utilizing
Kubernetes RBAC, GKE
provides another
layer for us to secure
cluster access, this time around
a user's network identity.
Even if a user is already setup
with GCP IAM and Kubernetes
RBAC correctly, we may also
want to verify the network
from which they are running.
In GKE, authorized
networks is a feature
that allows us to only
enable communication
with the Kubernetes control
plane in our GKE clusters
from a trusted set
of IP addresses.
This adds an additional
layer of security
to not only ensure that
our user is authorized
to perform a certain
set of actions,
but is also performing these
actions from a trusted network
perimeter.
To recap, configuring
GCP IAM, Kubernetes RBAC,
and GKE authorized
networks is a great place
to start when building
a GKE cluster that
adheres to your organization's
security best practices.
Now that we've
covered the essentials
for securing cluster
access in GKE,
visit the links
here to learn more.
With the concepts
discussed in this video,
we're confident
you'll be on your way
to building a GKE cluster
that suits your needs.
Stay tuned as we expand on other
GKE topics in "GKE Essentials."